there are plenty of 90 Sci-Fi movies
that don't hold up visually today CGI
has come a long way in the past three
decades and movies that went all in on
the technology back then are really
starting to show their age the fifth
element has no shortage of special
effects but the movie still looks
fantastic today because so much of what
happens on screen was created
practically Luke bassan knew that his
movie was going to demand an excessive
amount of visual effects it took more
than 160 people to create the 220 shots
that made it into the movie and the team
filmed plenty more that didn't survive
the editing room bassan employed model
makers and artists to make his world as
realistic as possible the spaceships
shown in the movie Are Real Models so is
Corbin's taxi and even some of the New
York city streets that he flies it down
a second viewing gives one plenty of
time to really appreciate the level of
effort that wi into making The Fifth
Element as visually engaging as it is